[Música]
en las últimas décadas ha tenido un
impacto significativo en todas nuestras
vidas de general es sólo un ejemplo
hace 25 años mi novia que es actualmente
mi esposa y que me acompaña en esta
sesión
[Aplausos]
y en tan sólo dos formas de comunicarnos
o lo hacíamos vía telefónica a través de
una operadora puesto que nuestros
hogares no contaban con discado directo
o lo hacíamos por
[Música]
la de ese año y 202 cartas de comunidad
mi esposa curva y entonces en
contestarme
[Música]
y es por eso que estábamos en su
presentación
de tal manera lo significativo
[Música]
responder
tomaron otros 15 días de luto con lo
cual siempre de comunicación tomaba 30
días
lo mejor que yo voy a decir
15 días
[Música]
para dar
las maravillosas
y
[Música]
pero también nos permitía
la comunicación
[Música]
guau podíamos comunicarnos el tiempo
no con toda la calidad
[Música]
y todos
1968 es así
y muchas cosas
[Música]
también es maravilloso que hizo que
nosotros los niños
[Música]
la suerte de las casas y una cantidad de
entre 5 y 6
ahora
[Música]
listas
de todas las tecnologías
[Música]
pero verdaderamente importante lo
importante son las personas a proponer
teorías nuevas pruebas ya conocidos que
nos permitían hacer las cosas
[Música]
pero las ideas
el verdadero
[Música]
son aquellas de as que ha estado
dispuesto a llegar
[Música]
son personas
no hubiera por cálculo hecho de la india
propuesto la teoría de la tierra al
centro
en la actualidad todos sabemos que esa
teoría del cielo
hay otro tipo de personas que no se
atienden
y se encuentran cómodos porque tienen
demasiado miedo artículo como para poder
enfrentar las críticas
4 - sin embargo las teorías propias
insisto sobre el mismo regalo que la
persona le puede hacer a la comunidad
de manera técnica después considerar
[Música]
una falta tecnológica activa
y la función consiste
[Música]
algunas personas tienen ideas más
interesantes que es
por ejemplo una mujer tales
ustedes qué hoyos durante acuerdo y si
todos estaban servicios de comunicación
se extienden si nuestras transmisiones
de esta manera
ojalá con el máximo de cuatro
y diez más que gestionar
es agradable encontrar en nuestras
plazas todo este tipo de basurales
quizás sea momento de que empecemos a
trabajar en sistemas de reciclaje más
eficientes
una cosa que nosotros nos encontramos
todos los días en nuestros mercados
populares fíjense ustedes este caos
tenemos una fruta maravillosa tenemos
unas canastas que tienen una utilidad
increíble tenemos mesas y gente que está
atendiendo a estos mercados pero
desafortunadamente todo esto es un
desorden porque no hacemos que se vean
más así son las mismas mesas las mismas
canastas las mismas frutas pero
presentadas de otra manera es que el
problema de no atrevernos a proponer
teorías propias a buscar un cambio sobre
los problemas existentes genera como
consecuencia que nos hagamos indolentes
ante la realidad que los seres humanos
pensemos que debemos recibir menos de lo
que realmente nos merecemos por tanto
invitó nuevamente a que ustedes
propongan sus ideas y le den ese
maravilloso regalo al mundo
más allá de eso yo creo que este momento
eso ya no es opcional existen varios
estudios a nivel mundial en los que se
demuestra que a partir del año 2020 todo
el conocimiento del planeta se va a
duplicar cada 74 días esto nos plantea
dos problemas muy serios el primero como
nos vamos a mantener actualizados como
profesionales y el segundo cómo vamos a
actuar ante problemas que no tienen
soluciones documentadas en los libros
de hecho prácticamente mi vida y ahora
me encontrado con nada que sea tal como
está escrito en los libros
ahora las personas que se atreven a
proponer tareas de teoremas propios o
teorías propias deben tener conciencia
de que esas teorías tienen que cumplir
con al menos tres principios primero
deben abordar un problema real para
aquellos que vieron la película it y el
extraterrestre no sé quienes vieron
podría levantar la mano
todos los que han visto it y les doy una
mala noticia resulta que no ha llegado y
por tanto no tenemos por qué encontrar
la forma de enviarlo de vuelta a casa
los problemas tienen que ser los
problemas que podemos y debemos resolver
en la actualidad segundo tiene que ser
técnica y económicamente eficientes eso
no quiere decir que sean económicamente
eficientes o técnicamente factibles el
primer día que no está idea salió
probablemente vamos a tener que luchar
por muchos años generando tecnologías
intermedias y buscando la factibilidad
económica para que a lo mejor nuestras
ideas salgan a producción luego de
muchos años o quizás incluso luego de
nuestra vida pero es importante que ya
estén descritas y que existan también
tienen que ser ideas o teorías propias
completamente éticas apegadas a la
legislación apegadas a nuestras
creencias y que afecten de la menor
manera posible a los terceros que no
están involucrados en este proceso
las personas que son capaces de generar
teorías propias tienen a mi forma de ver
al menos cuatro características
importantes la primera tienen un
altísimo nivel de información y aquí
hablo de información transdisciplinaria
no solamente aquella que se adquiere en
nuestro proceso educativo sino aquella
que se adquiere a través de nuestro
interés por leer y aprender de otras
cosas sin la posibilidad de adquirir
conocimiento de otras disciplinas
steve jobs en su famoso discurso en la
universidad de stanford dijo que el
momento que cambió su vida fue cuando él
asistió a un curso de caligrafía y
descubrió la belleza que tenía las
distintas formas de letras y los estilos
de tipos de letras y entonces decidió
que las computadoras debían poder
soportar esa funcionalidad el resultado
es que la informática la usabilidad de
los sistemas de información cambió para
siempre
la segunda característica que tienen
estas personas es el amar y apegarse a
la intuición
el genio intuitivo más grande que ha
existido es albert eisntein la intuición
entendida como la capacidad de las
personas que compran de comprender
entender problemas y proponer soluciones
sin uso directo de la razón
albert einstein decía que la mente
intuitiva es un regalo divino y la mente
racional su fiel sirviente
y continuaba diciendo que el problema
grande de la sociedad es que amamos
mucho al sirviente y dejamos de lado al
regalo que nos ha dado la vida
el tercer la tercera característica de
los que son capaces de proponer teorías
propias es que son creativos pero no
solamente que son creativos sino que
están dispuestos a hacer el ridículo y
además afrontar el criticismo sobre sus
ideas esto es natural en las personas
que están dispuestos a proponer una
nueva idea por último yo creo que la
característica más importante que tienen
estos pensadores sí es la capacidad de
convicción sobre sobre esas ideas la
convicción va más allá de las razones es
lo que nos permite continuar
desarrollando nuestro pensamiento a lo
largo del tiempo cuando nos encontramos
dificultades en el camino
nuevamente insisto yo no encuentro casi
ninguna actividad de mi vida en la cual
las cosas hayan estado como se decía en
los libros
nadie en mente no mientras estudiaba
tecnología electrónica para ser un
ayudante técnico en quirófanos de los
años que servi en las cirugías
laparoscópicas y nadie me preparó en mi
carrera de ingeniero informático para
ser el director ejecutivo el gerente de
la grieta académica nacional
todo eso tuve que aprenderlo sobre la
marcha proponiendo mis propias ideas con
mi propia intuición con mis propias
ganas y mi convicción de que esos
trabajos eran importantes para la
sociedad pero yo creo que todos estos
principios son aplicables a
absolutamente todos los aspectos de
nuestra vida y no solamente a la
profesión y seguirme nuevamente dar un
ejemplo en mi familia cuando mi esposa y
yo decidimos casarnos tuvimos que
aprobar a voluntad dar uno de los
grandes problemas que afrontan todas las
personas de la humanidad como unirnos y
formar nuestra propia familia tuvimos
que esperar algún tiempo para que eso
fuera viable económicamente pero que
sobre todo tuviéramos la suficiente
madurez como para sentirnos listos para
dar ese paso y lo hicimos de la manera
más ética sigue
a nuestras creencias aceptando
dirigiéndonos a las leyes de nuestro
país y con el menor impacto posible para
la sociedad de hecho creo que el impacto
más grande fue la tristeza que tuvieron
nuestros padres de ya no tenerlos al día
siguiente en sus casas
pero a lo largo de estos ya 28 años de
vida que llevo con mi esposa / novio y
esposo
hemos tenido que utilizar en múltiples
ocasiones los factores que yo creo que
tienen que tener aquellos que se
proponen o se atreven a proponer sus
propias ideas solo por empezar tuve que
ser muy creativo para poder conquistar
no crean que fue fácil hasta me dijo no
cuando me declaré
tuvimos a lo largo de estos años que
llenarlos de información para entender
qué decisiones teníamos que tomar a
futuro y tuvimos que aceptar que nuestra
intuición tenía mucho más razón que las
razones en muchas ocasiones y finalmente
lo que hemos tenido a lo largo de estos
casi 24 años de matrimonio es una firme
convicción de lo que hemos estado
haciendo es lo más importante en
nuestras vidas como consecuencia estoy
de felices de mostrarles cuál ha sido
nuestros resultados
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]